[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
doors that prefer to think of a Dear
John and Hank it's a comedy podcast
where two brothers answer you a question
can be devious advice and binky while
the week's news from both Mars and AFC
Wimbledon I've heard some good things
about AFC Wimbledon John but I guess
we'll get to that later how you do it
I'm doing well Hank as you may know I've
for many months been promising to do a
podcast called the Anthropocene reviewed
in which I reviewed different facets of
the human centered planet and I have
made that podcast and it is available
for download now wherever you get your
podcasts anywhere and right now actually
it's number 9 on the iTunes charts so
even though Anthropocene is very hard to
spell and it's kind of hard to search
for the Anthropocene movement the first
episodes for doing very well it's about
Canada geese which bird species that
almost went extinct about that 90 years
ago and now is something of a pest
species I would argue and diet dr.
pepper the zero calorie soda that I
argue in in this episode of the
Anthropocene reviewed is one of the
greatest achievements in the history of
the human species
I mean I feel like we we hit the
sponsorships early job well I just
wanted to get it out there you know you
can go search for the Anthropocene
reviewed and this it's only 17 minutes
long it's not like an episode of dear
Hank and John where you got to put like
an hour of your life into it Oh Hank I
just learned I just saw an email from
you ho boy yeah so I have I have stuff
going on as well oh we both have lots of
things have been really it's been a
stressful week but one of the things
that has happened is I just got some
book covers in and I sent these ones to
John because I do you like them I like
all these it's five of them that I'm
looking at right now and I unfortunately
I think the bad news is that I like all
five a lot do you like them I like them
a lot the first the first the first
round I liked less and I didn't even
send to you and this one this one's I
like a lot especially like the middle
one the one that's right in the middle
of the five yeah I mean there's sort of
two different background designs I like
them both who's the coverage I like it I
guess you can't say because you don't
know if this person
they won't tell they won't tell me the
person is apparently very nervous to be
working with me so they won't tell me
who the cover designer is they like
nervous because they know it's gonna be
so bad for their career to be associated
with Hank green I think I think they're
nervous because they they know that I
can be fairly opinionated about design
yeah yeah I I don't know actually I
might like one more than I like three
but I like all five of them so that's
good news yeah one is one is a little
bit too much contrast for my take my
taste I really like that we're just
talking about the covers of no one can Z
well they'll eventually see one of the
five probably actually they'll probably
see some different version of one of the
five with some kind of pull quote on it
well Hank I guess we've both now managed
to insert some promo here in the first
couple minutes of dear Hank and John but
I just like to point out that you once
again failed to say the name of your
frickin book which is an absolutely
remarkable thing available for pre-order
now it comes out September 25th and it's
great thank you John for being my for
being my promo fairy I mean I will be
your hype man all day long let's answer
some questions from earlier race this
first question comes from Jane who asks
dear Hank and John I am in high school
and we just had to like a get to know me
assignment the questions were mostly
things like when's your birthday and
what's your future career plans but one
of the questions stumped me the question
was what's your favorite thing on the
internet right now I don't really
understand what this means and so I was
wondering what is your favorite thing on
the internet right now there are many
shades Jade it's a great question well
first I I gotta say that like my feet I
feel like it's easier to answer the its
what's my favorite thing on the internet
right now than it is to answer what's my
future career I don't know what my
future I'm 37 years old and I don't know
what my future career plans are I think
I'm just gonna be a professional
reviewer of Diet Dr Pepper from here on
out I think that's it yeah I mean it's a
good plans John um yeah I mean I agree I
think what's your favorite thing on the
internet right now is a little bit of a
difficult question right now on the
Internet
but I do still have lots of favorite
things on the internet you know Hank
knows but my favorite thing on the
internet is right now because it's a
acting his algorithmically generated
YouTube view suggestions because we have
the same youtube blog yeah my favorite
thing on the internet right now I cannot
can I tell the people what it is can I
make a guess yes is it some guy playing
football manager it's not just some guy
playing football manager it's doctor
it's dr. Ben gfm playing football
manager and he plays as like a seventh
tier team called I care you know the
river in London James Thames yeah the
the Thames river the rosey Otto
literally just booed from the from the
next door he plays as like a seventh
tier soccer team and he's trying to like
make his way up through the league and
there are all these characters involved
like there's a guy who reports on the
progress of the team called Ben's Sports
News and they're they're all played by
like thinly disguised versions of him
and when he's talking on the phone he's
using his television remote control and
he's just hilarious and also I am deeply
involved in the life of this imaginary
seventh tier football team so that's my
favorite thing on the internet right now
Hank what's your favourite thing I mean
I'm looking at my youtube view history
right now and it would appear that my
favorite thing on the internet right now
is either animatics of podcasts
including my own podcast thank you to
vegeto's for making those and/or ants
Canada which is an amped YouTube channel
where the guy has ants and he takes care
of his ants it's real cool is it is it
like the marble Olympics like do you get
involved in the lives of the ancestors
yeah no they're they're a bunch of
different nations of amps cuz he's got
two outs and they they have a whole sort
of like area and and you know it's it
could be difficult the life of an ant
keeper and this guy is just really into
it and has his own ant farm business and
he also separately has a very popular
like parody music video career it's fun
under the channel Mikey Bustos so I've
ever heard of Mikey Bustos he also has
an ant channel and his aunt Channel is
one of them I just like oh yes this is
exactly what YouTube is for that's great
I love that there are
andt channel creators out there I love
the Marvel Olympics I love dr. Benji FM
I've just got that there are still so
many weird and beautiful things in the
world
speaking of which before we get off this
topic there's just one other YouTube
creator I want to highlight she just did
a million subscribers do you watch Elle
Mills Hank oh yeah of course I watch
Ellen else she's like she's she's
completely taken video blogging to a
whole new level that I didn't know she
really has she just did a million
subscribers and she she threw herself a
full-blown high school graduation in
which she graduated from irrelevant see
video she gives like the valedictorian
speech as the only graduate from
irrelevant see in the audience and the
audience is like her sister her brother
one of her friends and her mom well good
oh my god it's magical it's just so
there is oh my god going through my
YouTube watch history it's just just a
whole I said it's an adventure of the
last weeks of my life the places my
brain was and then occasionally where
your brain was and me being like why on
earth were you watching this John it's
very it's a fun thing that you and I can
spend some time looking at what each
other watches and it also keeps me from
watching things that are exceptionally
embarrassing because I know that you
will notice that's right that's right so
Hank only occasionally watches recaps of
Vanderpump rules our next question comes
from Annie who writes I'm just kidding
on no that's not anything to be
embarrassed about
all right this next question comes from
Annie who writes Dear John and Hank my
mom is insisting that I attend the
senior prom however I have no one to go
with since all of my friends are already
in well-established relationships with
the significant other should I pretend
to go to the prom and then sneak off and
spend the night alone in a nearby target
or should I come up with a devious plot
to break up one of the pairs of my
friends Oh Annie I mean that is a false
dichotomy because for one thing you can
do both you could definitely both break
up your friends and go spend a way too
much time inside of a target I don't
know that you want to do either
those things I definitely had some of my
most fun times as a person who was not
going to prom with another person oh you
went to prom like by yourself yeah well
I didn't go by myself I went with other
people but I was not in I was not part
of a couple well I went to prom I um my
high school did not have a prom but I
did go to two different high school
proms with dates but both those dates
were friends not not girlfriends
although one of them I did kiss and she
went on to become like a professional
trumpet player but that is a different
story
it's not like making a better kiss I'm
just telling you what happened but like
so anyway is there like a
professionalism to the to the to the
kiss of a trumpet player that you do not
get with just a normal kiss because the
trumpet player has developed a whole new
set of muscles and skills with regard to
lip Fitness I think it was um their
first French kiss is my answer to your
question so I know is it it's not gonna
it wasn't I mean was it gonna like win
an Academy Award no but also I mean it
was I in a position to criticize also no
so it was just a couple of kids doing
their best that's all I'm gonna say
about it we're gonna move on I'm sorry
even brought it up it's not relevant to
your situation and yeah I mean either
you just go without a date which I don't
think is that big of a deal or you know
you purchase a date from the internet oh
you know my most embarrassing person
asking to the prom was John tell me
about it I don't I don't know now I
don't want to tell you cuz it's pretty
embarrassing now that I'm famous if
there's no way it's gonna make the top
too embarrassing Hank Green's stories
there is no way unlikely it's not gonna
be as embarrassing as you faking a
British accent for nine months and it's
not gonna be as embarrassing as the
thing that's more embarrassing than that
that we never talked about so out my
friends and I went to Denny's a lot as
as youth when we were in high school and
and there was a Denny's waitress who
I don't know maybe maybe three or four
years older than us and I go god it's
already very embarrassed I thought that
she was very attractive and she was
always they know and would serve us
every time and it got to be to the point
where it felt a little bit like this
person was in addition to being our
waitress a friend and so I asked her to
prom and she said no think about it she
like looked me in the eyes and she was
like okay like the last thing I am going
to do is go to a high school prom with a
high school guy when I am at like a 21
year old woman that is just never gonna
happen and yeah so I don't know I didn't
expect that but the amazing thing was
that what I expected was kind of all of
my friends to chuckle in unison but what
didn't happened instead was they all
looked at me like I was bad and had made
a huge mistake which was accurate they
were yeah Kodak earth yeah definitely oh
that is cringy yeah I mean it doesn't
make the top five most embarrassing Hank
green stories to me but it's definitely
a Cringer yeah the other thing Annie is
that you have a few months to figure
this out right so bright you know how
sometimes on the internet you'll see
like this person asked Ryan Gosling to
prom and then Ryan Gosling had a movie
to promote so he agreed to go hmm as
part of his movie promotion like the
agents probably tricked him into it or
he was on a junket and he was in New
York anyway or whatever just do that
just start asking Ryan Gosling to frog
it's never too soon they're just a list
of like of potential potential celebrity
prom dates somewhere has Ryan Gosling
gone to prom with a Rando it looks like
not it looks like no the good news is
though John that there are photographs
from Ryan Gosling's prom is a little
holy why I think that's a lie this guy
just looks like Ryan Gosling Annie if
I've learned anything from watching a
lot of 80s high school movie it's that
this is going to work itself out it's
only February
you have so many twists and roundabouts
between now and prom that everything is
gonna work out right isn't prom in April
usually I could not have stored that
information in my brain that long it's
just never going to have happened it's
all gonna work out Annie don't don't be
don't worry everything's gonna be fine
and I will say and I will say Annie you
are used to hanging out with couples as
being friends with couples and you will
just do that again
but in nicer clothes with punch it'll be
great it'll be fine this next question
comes from Haneen who asks dear Hank and
John the other day I was sitting in
biology lecture when my professor
decided to stop walking and stand by a
student about three rows ahead of me my
professor typically walks as she
lectures the student began eating an
orange and that's all well and good I've
seen people eat weirder items during
lecture but the problem was she was
eating it as if it were an apple with
the peel is this a thing maybe it's a
new health fad are there areas of the
world where people don't peel their
oranges before eating them is she from
an alternate universe please help me my
brain doesn't like this rage against the
haneen that's a great name specifics I
know for knowing good I did a little bit
of research about this hanging oh oh is
it is it like is it like a genetically
modified human thing where now people
can eat the orange peel because they
like got some cow genes or something no
I suspect that this is more of a
Coneheads thing where you can spot the
aliens because they think that they're
performing normal human actions but
occasionally they'll do something
extremely weird so I think what's
happening here is that you are in an
alien contact situation in which you are
dealing with and intelligence that is
not from the planet Earth
alternately there is another possibility
which is that the person who is eating
this orange with the peel on it ended up
on the same weird web sites that I ended
up on that insists that eating orange
peel can save you from all manner of
health problems including clearing your
lungs when you have an extremely bad
cold okay I'm sure we've all been there
Hank you know how it is a little bit of
vitamin C
one whole peel of an orange and you feel
better almost instantaneously and there
are a number of other health benefits
that are touted with orange peels
however the the u.s. the United States
Agriculture part of the government I
don't know what they're called USDA
Haneen I didn't google this extensively
the USDA had a couple of concerns one
you don't really know what's on that
orange peel a lot of times its chemicals
and any chemicals that you don't want to
consume and to eating orange peel can be
very difficult to digest which can cause
diarrhea sure might have some you might
have some orange peel diarrhea basically
I don't recommend eating orange peels
John there has to be a way to tell the
difference between a health nut who is
confused about the benefits of orange
peels and a space alien who doesn't
understand how fruits work and I have
several suggestions one I have heard
that this has not been confirmed to me
that if you hold up a fork horizontally
in front of one of your eyes and look
through it you will be able to tell if
it's an alien that is having a hologram
projected around it or if it's human
being so just before class starts walk
around to the fork and then stare
directly into this person's face holding
a fork up over your eye and see what you
see that's a good idea and that won't
and then we'll get a question from that
person who's like Dear John and Hank
every day before class and then second
secondarily just make friends cuz
ultimately like either you're gonna make
friends with somebody and you're gonna
discover that they're not an alien or
you will be friends with an alien right
both are great outcomes both are great
outcomes alright Hank this next question
comes from Jenna and it's one that I
feel that I need answered because now I
have a new apocalyptic worry she writes
dear John and Hank I was wondering what
would happen if all the plants just
cease to exist would we then die too
because there would be no oxygen to
Attar's and Kiwis Jenna now Hank before
you get into the answer I just want to
point out to Jenna because I believe
that she is probably from New Zealand
based on her sign off that the plural of
tuatara is tuatara so it's tuatara
and Kiwis I apologize for being pedantic
now Hank would we all die if all of the
plants just ceased to exist uh we
definitely would die if all of the
plants ceased to exist but we would die
along of starvation way before we died
of suffocation so there's a lot of
oxygen in the atmosphere and while it is
always being replenished like the stuff
that we are consuming is being
regenerated it would take if it were
just humans on the order of like a
thousand years to consume all the oxygen
so if we were able to like suck it out
and store it and then put it in tanks we
could live a pretty long time of course
most of the oxygen on earth is consumed
by things that aren't humans including
non-biological processes like oxidation
general like fires and stuff and but the
like not having plants would be a bigger
problem for the food web then like all
the cows would die within a couple weeks
and then all the people would die within
a few weeks of that so they like just
wouldn't like all all the food is based
on based on plants right so if the if
the plants all died we would have a mad
rush to try and make more plants before
we started worrying about oxygen so have
a conversation with a nearby plant and
say thank you very much please don't die
specifically if that plant bears some
kind of food so like grass not so much
that can all die but like you know if
you got a weird orange tree where the
super nutritious orange peels you want
to stick around for that one and say
thank you very much for the for the
weird creepy alien sustenance all right
I mean that makes me feel a little bit
better because I feel like probably all
the plants won't die all at once it
seems very unlikely there many of them
are quite Hardy this next question comes
from Will who asks dear Hank and John
sometimes people say my friends call me
insert nickname here so I was wondering
is this the same thing as saying you can
call me or should call me this name like
because you have said that am I your
friend now or do I just store that
information in case we become friends
later cordially wishing you will I don't
know I mean I've been in this situation
before where somebody will say
my name is Frank but people call me
Johnny
and then I'll say right well now I'm in
a pickle why did you even tell me about
Frank why is Frank even if that like I
don't want to know like what your
parents named you I want to know what to
call you Frank will what Johnny whatever
it was so what percentage of people call
you Johnny is it everybody yeah is this
some piece I didn't name that you're
like you had to use for a while because
of a witness protection thing but now
you're going back to your old name and
you're trying to make a bridge I need
more information I need to say here's
what you should say if you're you should
say my name is Frank but you can call me
Johnny it's still weird I don't know
that's that's weird that's extra weird
because it's like wait if that just so
you'll remember me or are you trying to
let give me false information so that
maybe in the future I won't be uh-oh
so when the private investigator says it
comes to your house and says hey do you
know a guy named Frank you'll think no I
don't know any Frank I do know what got
in him Johnny yeah and then they'll be
completely incognito he's a spy
is what they're saying it's possible I
don't think there are any spies named
Frank or Johnny you know have that
there's a weird thing when you are maybe
moving to a new place are you going off
to school or you're starting a new job
you can kind of change your name like
you could just be and I've had friends
who have done this and it feels kind of
inauthentic to the person I've talked to
them about it I was like oh I didn't
realize that that your other friends
called you Timothy instead of Tim and
and then but you introduced to yourself
to all of us as Tim and he's like yeah
and it's always felt a little weird and
it's like well to us it feels very
normal like you can totally do that
right it's fast like a you don't I'm not
saying you should I'm just saying like
that's a weird thing that we're capable
of as humans when we start a new thing
you could just be like I've decided that
my name's cow right yeah no you can be
AI a slightly off-topic but I always
liked the name cow it's nice yeah that
reminds me a little bit Hank of when I
was in sixth grade I went to a different
middle school because I had just been
bullying so much of my first middle
school and I decided I was gonna give
myself a nickname going into my new
school that everyone would call me but I
also felt that I needed a nickname that
seemed realistic given my level of
nerdiness so high okay okay I get I like
where we're going I attempted to get
people in this new school to call me
shrimp this I mean it's amazing how
similar a story I have to them do you
really I do
Wow I did and of course it completely
failed but also when you go to a new
school and you say my name's John but
people call me shrimp it doesn't it just
it doesn't work on every level like it
fails it fails at doing all of the
things that you want to do what what is
your story my story so I I went off to
summer camp one year and and everybody
at summer camp started calling me bug
which is a very like a shrimp is
basically a bug that lives in the water
that's an ocean and it's an ocean bug
and also in lakes though I'll be there
are freshwater shrimp oh my god it's
really is it like dead ants episode of
dear Hank and John so I I just and I
came back from summer camp and then I
was going back to school and I was like
I would like everyone to keep calling me
bug because I thought it was fun and it
was cute and I liked it and like it felt
very supportive and like a normal thing
to be called bug and so I started to
like to sort of seed the the water with
bug and tell people that like they could
call me and then immediately it became
like a like a like a term of abuse like
they people called me bug as a thing to
call me to be mean to me and I could
tell the difference and it was no longer
a nickname it was like a bully name and
it's amazing it was like the same name
but the context it was in and the way
that people were using it it was like oh
great now I have created a great way for
people to make me feel bad about myself
with this word instead of feel good
about myself it was very interesting how
that one word could mean different
things to me in different contexts and I
immediately regretted it and it was bad
so much of life is contextual and so
much of language is contextual but I
just
to be absolutely clear about something
which is that no one agreed to call me
shrimp ever John maybe that's better
yeah maybe what you got to say you got
if you want somebody to call you a
nickname you got it because we have a
guy in our office named tuna his name is
not actually tuna but he was like hello
I'm tuna right you don't say hello I'm
Joe and my end people call me to night
you just say I am tuna right my name is
tuna what's your name
yeah speaking of which Hank we've have
another question this one comes from Sam
and Michael who asked Dear John and Hank
my girlfriend and I live in a downtown
apartment and our Wi-Fi name is
nerdfighter related and so is our
password we recently discovered that
there's a person who's been using our
Wi-Fi what do we do should we assume
that because they must be a fellow
nerdfighter that they're a good person
and we shouldn't kick them off mm-hmm
no no the problem I've identified
several brava
maybe we should go around our building
looking for people with android phones
who watch of all brothers hoping to make
a new friend no again dubious advice
unappreciated not managing an internet
cafe Sam and Michael Oh guys first of
all I think that may be the first time
we've ever gotten a question from two
people and two years of doing this
podcast I think we've gotten a couple
before but you're right it's it's a
rarity I have but secondly ya know like
don't steal other people's Wi-Fi and
also this was not a LED this was not
like it like I happened into it it's not
like oh this person's Wi-Fi is
nerdfighter 2007 I'll click on that and
oh I'm just in know they had to guess
your password they had to like go in and
brute-force hack your Wi-Fi right there
are two situations here one is that the
name of your Wi-Fi is the password is
dftba and then the password is dftba
yeah another situation Sam and Michael
is bad it's bad yeah and that I mean
it's also possible that they aren't even
nerdfighters and they just hacked your
Wi-Fi yeah I think that you need to be
taking this slightly more seriously than
you're taking it
at least based on what I can find out
about Hank just from knowing what
YouTube videos he watches I'm not sure
they want somebody who's really good at
hacking Wi-Fi passwords with access to
your Wi-Fi so if I were you I would
change the Wi-Fi password and the
network name and what we're gonna do for
you now Sam and Michael is we are going
to give you both a new network name ah
and a new password so that if this
person really is a nerdfighter then then
if they reacts s it maybe then you can
talk to them Hank what name of Sam and
Michael's new wireless network an
absolutely remarkable thing that's a
great that's great Hank and the password
is available for pre-order now nine two
five two zero one eight two zero one
eight that's a great finish Hank I don't
know why that took me so long that is
the password and if they can brute-force
hack that password then you need to pan
it you need to move just get out well or
you change the password to come meet me
in apartment no that sounds that sounds
bad that's an apartment 212 this next
question we've got another question that
we're gonna do before our sponsors and
maybe some send some updates and
corrections this comes from Sarah who
asks dear Hank and John how does Legolas
never run out of arrows
does he swiftly retrieve them from those
he has pierced do they spontaneously
regenerate in his elvish knapsack I
can't seem to wrap my head around it or
I also can't seem to wrap my head around
the phrase I can't wrap my head around
something anywho just wondering
try me tops Sara triceratop well a
little while to get that that one that's
there it is excellent first of all John
let's hit the wrap your head around
something because never do I even want
to like have the visualization of like
my head becoming made of play-doh and it
it
sort of like wrapping around and like
like a bacteria wrapping around
information and then digesting it inside
with my with my cytoplasm I don't like
it
yeah I was thinking of it as a white
blood cell eating a virus but you're
right it's better to think of it as a
bacterial cell eating flesh yeah that's
way better it's much better
everybody everybody like everybody likes
the word flea you know like it does no
one turns off the podcast as soon as we
say the word flow you saying it sounds
gross it does seem like the phrase wrap
my head around something is a phrase
that was created by a non-human sentient
species they're like yeah that's how it
works right correct
like that's how artificial a head around
that correct fellow human all right and
then they eat the orange with the peel
still on it it does seem like that's how
artificial intelligence learns by like
surrounding a fact rather than learning
it but to your larger question Sarah I
have no effing idea uh I mean now I want
to watch but there's definitely moments
where I feel like I mean in the books
there's definitely moments where Legolas
runs out of arrows and he talks about
needing to get more arrows or like he
goes and collects them I think during
the Battle of Helm's Deep he like goes
and he's like I have to go find more
arrows but in the movie he definitely
starts to use knives he starts to cut
people oh so he runs out he doesn't know
maybe when he does run out of arrows
yeah so maybe the knives come out when
he's run out of arrows I don't know
maybe he's just like he's still got
arrows and but he's also knifing and why
not maybe he's just got too close to
stab people with arrows which he
occasionally does where he's like and I
was gonna shoot you but you're too close
so Wow jab rob so there yeah we've got
our answer so today's brought to you by
Lego losses knives Lego losses knives
back up back up this podcast has also
brought to you by the kiss of a
trumpeter just doing their best
today's podcast is also brought to you
by the u.s. agriculture part of the
government the US Agriculture far the
government serving Americans and their
agricultural needs since 1789 and
brought to you by freshwater shrimp
freshwater shrimp they're around man
don't just rate the bar they pair they
pair very well with tuatara we also have
a real sponsor today Hank oh do we
it's the Anthropocene reviewed available
now on iTunes we've got a number of new
things new things happening right now
you know got the book we got the
Anthropocene reviewed we've also Mental
Floss just started up scatterbrained on
the Mental Floss Channel yeah I'm really
excited about that it's hosted by six or
seven different people a really
wonderful group of people I don't just
say that because I am part of them and
every episode we tackle a different big
topic in lots of different ways
so the first episodes about the Winter
Olympics and we take a lot of different
approaches to learning about the Winter
Olympics it's a lot of fun you can find
out more at YouTube commenter floss
video we also have Aeons which is our
project with PBS digital that we've
loved working on if you're interested in
history before history the history of
the ancient world and what life looked
like before we were around check out
eons it's really wonderful Seth who
works on that in our office just does an
amazing job with it yeah I love it I'm
also Co I'm co-hosting that one with a
couple of my friends and it's really
every time we do it I am just fascinated
and learned so much whenever I get a
script and the most recent episode is
called untangling the devil's corkscrew
which is a hundred year mystery of of
these very peculiar paleontological
discoveries that no one understood until
finally someone figured it out and I'm
not gonna tell you the answer John oh
wow gonna have to watch the video at
youtube.com slash yeah Wow you also
can't find out how many stars I gave
Canada geese unless you go listen to the
anthropocene reviewed
I know but I won't tell all right before
we get to the all-important news from
Mars and AFC Wimbledon we do have some
corrections to get to as well as an
update I need to give one of these
updates Hank it's about Benjamin
Harrison okay Benjamin Harrison the
president he was the President of the
United States and I now I understand him
too of obviously and inarguably been
America's most important president and I
want to apologize to all the bench of
the neighbors and fans out there
especially those who know me in real
life because I live very close to the
Benjamin Harrison home and Benjamin
Harrison's last and final resting place
and I want to apologize to everyone on
earth and all the all the Benjamin
Harrison fans out there I made a big
mistake not correcting Hank when he said
that Benjamin Harrison was the least
famous u.s. president also liam passed
along to us a sparkle quiz on US
presidents that gives us scientific
evidence that Benjamin Harrison is not
the least well-known of the u.s.
presidents needlessly couldn't well
known of the US presidents is wait for
it I do not believe it I do not believe
it Benjamin Harrison is 30 if he's not
even in the bottom 10 yeah the least
famous Rutherford behaved Rutherford B
Hayes who by the way I also have a
connection to he and I both attended
Kenyon College although I believe he did
not graduate other stuff to do yeah it
was the 1870s yeah well I guess it was
before that cuz he was president in the
1870s unless he went right out of school
very honest got elected Arian like yeah
I mean I feel like I've heard of
Rutherford behaves
it's just like Rutherford B Hayes and
Millard Fillmore those names like stick
in the brain because they're weird yeah
yeah the only way we'll put this list up
on the patreon so everybody can see and
you can see that whether you're a patron
or not you could see who the who the the
presidents that stick in people's brains
most are and that Benjamin Harrison is
indeed doing just fine really an
incredibly successful president so again
I am sorry to all of the Benjamin
Harrison fanatics out there I was
wrong and I this is my third apology I
think it's gonna be the last one but if
necessary I will apologize again just
keep hitting us with more reasons by
Benjamin Harrison should be the official
president of dear Hank and John we also
got a letter from Miriam who gives us an
extremely detailed breakdown of all of
the different kinds of Girl Scout
cookies and how it works and boy I tell
you what we not only are like Thin Mints
different but some of them are just
straight-up like not the same so yeah
there's there it is a it is a whole
whole world of variety out there for
people who move from one part of the
country to the next and say where's my
favorite Girl Scout cookie you just
don't have it this person actually looks
this person actually works at a little
brown Baker Council but there is a
council right next to us that is an ABC
bakery so there you have it and lastly I
just want to apologize to all of the
people out there who were deeply
offended by my saying that Joey was not
an important member of the friends cast
I'm sorry that you did not get my joke
Hank you will recall that just a few
short weeks ago AFC Wimbledon was
languishing in the relegation zone and
things were looking very dark indeed but
that Hank that was before the arrival of
the great Joe Piggott who joined AFC
Wimbledon here in the January transfer
window from fifth tier Maidstone United
I call him the Maidstone Ian Messi he
scored in his debut against Blackpool On
January 20th he scored a goal with his
second touch of the ball as an AFC
Wimbledon player he scored in his very
first game and then AFC Wimbledon went
to Bradford City away who were currently
fifth in the league one table and we
didn't just win Hank we scored four
goals whoa
did but Pickett didn't score any of
those goals right no not only did
Pickett not score any of those goals he
didn't even play until the 75th minute
but the important thing is that since
and Joe Piggott has arrived we've scored
six goals and given up none and we
Wow Hank a30 AFC Wimbledon has not given
up a goal in 2018 in a league 1 game we
did give up three goals to Tottenham in
the FA Cup but that's Tottenham
sure-sure uh we have not given up a
single goal in all of 2018 in fact we
already know now that we will not have
given up a goal in all of January it's
amazing so shout out to the defenders
shout out to George long our goalkeeper
who's on loan is doing a fantastic job
suddenly Wimbledon find themselves I
mean Hank there's hardly any oxygen up
here because we are in 16th place c4 so
high up the table if there's less oxygen
there's a little bit yeah I got their
event I know it wasn't my best work
we're in Sydney basically on Mars
we're basically marks we're in 16th
place and not that it matters but if you
have a look at the current relegation
zone Hank you will see that the
franchise currently plying its trade in
Milton Keynes is in 21st all right Don's
are going up and the franchise is going
down what's the news from Mars the news
from Mars John the Curiosity rover has
spent an awful long time five years now
on Mars driving around and during that
time it's been driving from the the base
of this lake bed up a an incline onto
the side of Mount sharp this mountain
and now that it has gotten some height
it actually has turned around or it's
turned its camera around and it's taken
a picture of where it came from the this
ancient lake bed where where there was
once water that we now thanks to the
Curiosity rover know without a doubt
there was long standing liquid water
there and it's beautiful and I'd love it
every time the curiosity team decides to
take a really high res large photo
especially panoramic photos so we're
gonna put both a video that gives you
sort of a panoramic view of what
Curiosity rover is seeing but also some
of the still images on the patreon well
everybody can see whether or not you're
a patron and I mean whenever I get a
picture like this of the surface of Mars
it it just like makes it so clear that
this alien world is out there in a way
that I don't like like I don't imagine
when I'm just thinking about the science
of Mars but especially now that we have
such high quality cameras on Mars on the
Curiosity rover it's able to take
basically the exact same quality images
if we had a professional photographer
there and it's just beautiful
it is a nice looking lake bed from from
the Vera Rubin Ridge as as curiosity
basically you know takes it takes a
little bit of time for to go to the what
do they call it the Overlook when you're
when you drive it along the highway so
it's not that it's overlooked it take a
nice pretty picture and also you can see
in this video where the Curiosity rover
landed and also tracks some of its some
of its five year journey across the
surface of Mars that's pretty cool I'm
looking at the picture now it's really
beautiful so we'll put that up on the
patreon where you can also listen to the
podcast we're about to record called
this week in Ryan's it's our incredibly
stupid podcast that we make for people
who subscribe to the patreon thank you
to everybody who does that and and helps
us out with the shows that we make at
complexly crash course scishow and the
rest of them and thanks to all of you
for listening hey what have we learned
today oh my goodness John what what
didn't we learn John today we learned a
number of embarrassing stories about you
and I going to prom that's true we also
learned that Hank likes to watch
Canadian ant colony YouTube and we
learned that John Green probably
wouldn't mind if you just started comedy
I'm shrimp and lastly we learned that
Sam and Michael's new Wi-Fi password is
an absolutely remarkable thing 9:25 2018
good see see it's it's a guerilla
marketing campaign John
this is really really it's only people's
passwords you literally can't and should
not share them it's so underground you
can't share thank you for potting with
me Hank thanks to everybody for
listening this podcast is edited by
nicholas jenkins who had a lot of work
to do with today's podcast we record
and it was an hour long and it's shorter
than that now so we're sorry Nick it's
produced by rosianna halse rojas and
Sheridan Gibson our head of community
and communications is Victoria bon
giorno the music that you're hearing now
in the beginning of the podcast is from
the Drake gunnarolla and as they say in
our hometown don't forget to be awesome
[Music]